when is seeing not believing a couple
years ago my friend sent me this photo
from om Qi which is the capital of Xin
Jiang province and northwest China on
this particular day she couldn't believe
her eyes checking the quality of the air
outside using this app on her iPad the
numbers were telling her the air quality
was good one on a scale of 500 but when
she looked outside she saw something
much different yes those are buildings
in the background but the data were
simply not telling the truth of what
people were seeing and breathing and
it's because they were failing to
measure PM 2.5 or fine particulate
pollution when PM 2.5 levels went off
the charts in 2012 or crazy bad as the
US Embassy once described it in a tweet
Chinese netizens took to social media
and they started to question why it was
that they were seeing this disconnect
between official air quality statistics
and what they were seeing and breathing
for themselves
now this questioning has led to an
environmental awakening of sorts in
China
forcing China's government to tackle its
pollution problems now China has the
opportunity to become a global
environmental leader with a picture that
I'll paint for you today is one that's
mixed there are some signs that are very
promising and there are other trends
that are more troubling that warrant
closer attention but now let's go back
to the story at hand I started to
witness the beginnings of China's green
evolution when I was a PhD student
conducting fieldwork in China in 2011 I
traveled all across the country seeking
answers to the question that I often got
myself from the skeptical outsider
what you mean China is doing something
on the environment they have
environmental policies what policies at
that time PM 2.5 data was considered too
politically sensitive and so the
government was keeping it secret but
citizens were becoming aware of its
harmful human health effects
and they were demanding greater
transparency on the part of the
government I actually started to see
some of this growing evolution and
awareness myself cropping up all over
China department stores for example
started to market these air purifiers
that could filter out harmful PM 2.5
citizens were also adopting PM 2.5 as
the title of music festivals and then I
went to a golf course in Shenzhen which
is in southern China and you can see
from this banner they're advertising a
retreat from PM 2.5 golf sub par but
don't breathe subpar air and then
Shanghai's Environmental Protection
Bureau decided to create a mascot named
after the air quality index to better
communicate the air quality data to its
people I call her a Qi girl and her
expression and hair color changes
depending on the quality of air outside
five years later and she's still the
mostly smiling face of Shanghai's air
quality and then in 2015
former CC TV reporter tai ching created
this documentary called under the dome
it would be likened to Rachel Carson's
Silent Spring and much like Rachel
Carson brought to attention the fact
that pesticides were harming human
health under the dome stamped into the
popular consciousness that air pollution
was leading to 1 million premature
deaths every year in China alone this
video garnered more than a hundred
million views in a single weekend before
China's government fearing that it might
incite some type of social unrest pulled
it from the internet but the damage had
already been done public outcry over air
pollution galvanized China's government
perhaps in an act of self-preservation
to think big and decisively about how it
could tackle the root of its air
pollution and many of its other
environmental problems its energy system
for UC in China about two-thirds of its
electricity comes from coal China has
more coal-fired power plants than any
other country in the world about 40
percent of the global total
and it's because of this fact that
China's government has decided since
2014 to wage a war on coal shutting down
small coal mines setting limits on coal
consumption even cancelling and
Australia's worth of coal-fired power
plants
they've also been making enormous
investments when it comes to clean and
renewable energy like hydropower wind
and solar and the pace and the scale of
this transformation has been absolutely
mind-blowing let me give you a couple
statistic to show you what I mean China
leads the world when it comes to
hydropower with 1/3 of total capacity
there's enough for every Chinese citizen
to power two homes in a single year from
hydropower alone you may have heard of
the Three Gorges Dam pictured here which
is the largest power station in the
world and is powered by water in terms
of wind power China has a third of the
global capacity this makes it the
number-one leader by far when we look at
solar China's also leading in fact they
crushed their 2020 target of installing
105 gigawatts of solar power this is
after the government already revised
upwards several times it's solar energy
target between 2009 and 2015
last year in seven months alone China
was able to install a whopping 35
gigawatts of solar power this is more
than half of what the US has combined in
total and China did this in just seven
months alone we can verify this
remarkable growth and solar power from
space like the startup space no has done
in this slide by 2020 China is on track
to generate Germany's entire electricity
consumption from just wind and solar
power alone it's pretty darn remarkable
and we see some evidence now that
China's efforts on clean energy is
actually having an effect not just on
air pollution reduction but also on
global climate change where China has
the world's largest carbon footprint if
we look at some of the data we can see
that China's coal consumption may have
already reached a peak
as early as 2013 this is a major reason
why China's government announced that
actually they've already achieved their
2020 carbon reduction pledge ahead of
schedule this reduction in coal
consumption is also directly driving
improvements in air quality across the
country as I've shown here in blue in
most major Chinese cities air pollution
has fallen by as much as 30 percent and
this reduction in air pollution is
actually leading people to live longer
lives in China on average two and a half
years more than they would have in 2013
in yellow we can see the cities that
have experienced the greatest
improvements in air quality but of
course as I mentioned at the beginning
of this talk we have to temper some of
this optimism with a healthy dose of
caution and that's largely because the
data are still being determined at the
end of last year after roughly three
years of pretty steady global carbon
emissions scientific projections suggest
that global emissions may be on the rise
again and that could be due to increases
in China's fossil fuel consumptions so
they may not have reached that peak that
I showed earlier but of course the
statistics and the data are still murky
and that's because China regularly
revises its coal statistics after the
fact actually it's funny since I've been
here I've been having a debate on
Twitter with other climate modelers
trying to figure out whether China's
carbon emissions have gone up gone down
or whether they're staying relatively
stable and of course China is still a
rapidly developing country it's still
experimenting with a range of policies
like dhoklas bike sharing which has been
hailed as a possible sustainable
transport solution but then we have
images of this bicycle graveyard that
tell a more cautionary tale sometimes
solutions can move too fast and outpaced
demand and of course coal is still king
in China at least for now so why should
we care about what China is doing on the
environment well what China does at home
on the environment can have global
implications
for the rest of us to borrow a line from
Tsai Jing were all under the same dome
an air pollution that originates in
China can travel beyond its borders and
affect populations as far away as those
in North America China is not only
exporting air pollution but they're also
exporting aid infrastructure technology
abroad President Xi Jinping in 2013
announced the one belt one road
initiative a massive one trillion US
dollar infrastructure investment project
and more than 60 other countries and
historically when we've seen that China
has made these infrastructure
investments abroad they haven't always
been clean the global environment
Institute a Chinese civil society group
found that in the last 15 years China
has invested in more than 240 coal-fired
power plants in more than 68 countries
affiliated with a one belt one Road
initiative that's more than a quarter of
China's own domestic coal fire capacity
that is exported abroad so we can see
that even though China is cleaning up at
home it's exporting some of that
pollution to other countries and
greenhouse gas emissions simply don't
have a passport so when we're trying to
evaluate this question of whether or not
China is actually leading we can still
as you can see it's still very much an
open debate but time is running out I've
studied the climate models and the
outlook is not good we still have a gap
between current policies and what needs
to happen if we want to avoid dangerous
climate change leadership is what we
desperately need but it's not coming
from the US for example the US
administration last June announced its
intent to withdraw from the Paris
climate agreement so now people are
looking towards China to fill that
leadership void so China is very much in
the driver's seat determining our global
environmental future what they do on
carbon trading on clean energy on air
pollution we can learn many lessons one
of those lessons is that clean energy is
not just good for the environment it can
save lives by reducing air pollution
it's also good for the
me we can see that last year China was
responsible for 30% of the global growth
in Korean jobs the US only six so the
picture that I've just painted for you
hopefully seems much different from
those mercury foggy air quality
statistics - a much clearer picture of
China's clean energy and even though
China is headed in the right direction
we know that there's still a very long
road ahead so let me ask you once more
is seen believing can we trust the data
and the statistics that show that
China's air quality is coming down and
that it's war on coal is actually having
an effect well let's take a look at some
of the latest satellite images of
China's solar power installations I want
you to look very closely at this image
can you see the proof may just be in the
pandas thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]